ils ont un coût avec mélenchon il veut
pas qu'un chroniqueur soit là ça aurait
pu être voué rixe aurait pu être agathe
aurait pu être quelqu'un d'autre je me
mets à leur place c'est quoi ces soit
hyper d'eric naulleau une émission
sachant que vous êtes là régulièrement
soit hyper mélenchon qui est un énorme
coup évidemment qu'ils choisissent
mélenchon est ce que vous allez d'accord
avec ses repères donnez moi mais j'ai
commencé exprimé en dix ans entre
l'animateur et le producteur et que je
comprenais une fille née la décision
je voudrais que depuis tout à l'heure je
voulais pas vous le dire filmer un
enfant c'est jean luc mélenchon jean luc
mélenchon nous regardent plus talent
puisqu'il est arrivé sur l'a1 nous
regarde et on va la voir dans un instant
jean luc mélenchon matin le voilà
bonsoir jean luc bonsoir nous vous
pouvez plus vous passer de moi non mais
qu'est ce qui se passe est arrivé à
hénin b c il ya un chemin de croix il se
passe et se passe un truc jean luc hees
ispat bon bravo déjà pour les adieux
bravo pour y roder jaillir pour bravo
pour hier pour les audiences parce que
je vous l'avais dit hier ont ciblé
vraiment les plus jeunes parce qu'on
veut vraiment qu'ils s'intéressent à la
politique qui va avoir une échéance en
2022 et elle va être importante et c'est
vrai que balances ton post c'est la
seule émission qui fait autant de jeunes
autant de gens de quinze 15 34 ans 15 24
ans 25 49 ans qui regardent une émission
politique vous le dis et donc jean lui
que vous avez tout explosé hier en
audience
voilà sur les jeunes ce qu'on était 3ème
chaîne nationale devant france 2 devant
france 3 devant taxi 5 sur tmc sur sur
les sur les ménagères et le c'est un
nicolas pernikoff c'est énorme
bon score et puis c'est important parce
que effectivement les jeunes il va
falloir qu'ils viennent aux urnes
césar est très important mais c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin de ce genre de débat mais
on est à quelques mois d'une grosse
échéance
jean luc mélenchon déjà est ce que ça
vous n'êtes pas trop fatigué parce qu'il
ya un nom ça finit tard oui très
honnêtement parce que vous vous êtes
coutumier pas comment vous faites mais
j'ai pas moi j'ai pas pu fermer l'oeil à
3h30 du matin autant que l'adrénaline
connais ses cendres entre temps j'ai
revu c'est aussi un jeu unique ans
retrouvé pendu hier et et raquel et puis
les autres d'autres amis parce que pour
nous la soirée elle était refrain tous
ceux qui sont directement gaz elle était
très globale d'été politique
c'est-à-dire y avait le plateau sur
lequel nous étions tous
ensemble on était encore en dire un mot
et puis il y avait ce qui se passait à
prendre 2 qui était un événement
consternant où on a vu deux personnes
débattre d'une loi alors que tout les
deux roule côté ça s'appelle plus un
débat c'est pas un dieu elle c'est un
duo et on a vu le ministre de
l'intérieur eux dire à madame le pen lui
reprocher d'être trop molle et d'être de
ne pas être assez hostile à l'islam
s'étaient donc je crois qu'on a un peu
notre présence l'amener en ont parlé sur
le plateau les échanges qui étaient très
divers parce que les points de vue
étaient pas
on n'était pas dans le consensus sur le
plateau 1 je m'empresse de dire moi j'ai
choisi personne je voudrais pas que nous
dise une chose pareille je vois
aujourd'hui art il veut attend une
seconde j'ai vu j'ai vu il fait venir
qui il veut les sujets je laissais tous
accepté sans exception parce qu'on y
arrivera t elle à l'hôpital
voilà moi j'ai dit à cyril hanouna au
tout début ça fait un moment que il m'a
vite et je suis reconnaissante ça parce
que il a pris un risque
hier soir hier je lui ai dit je viens si
c'est ce soir-là par là que c'est en
face de france 2 pour moi c'est une
protestation morale que je veux faire un
peu ce que c'est le service publiquement
et il aurait pu très bien dire écoute et
non à d'autres soir parce que là c'est
trop politique et que c'est trop frontal
il a accepté et je je je veux saluer çà
parce que c'était pas évident d'accepter
ça après j'ai dit à cyril hanouna moi je
suis fatigué du choc frontal avec des
gens violents excessif
on a vu tout à l'heure il ya même pas un
instant eric naulleau tira à raquel
garrido t'arrête tout de suite ou sinon
ça va mal se passer si tu continues je
m'en vais bon imaginez vous cachez pas
envie de vivre ça monsieur naulleau a
été pendant des années
assis à côté de monsieur zemmour et moi
invités dit dizaine de fois et j'ai
toujours dit non parce que je ne
supporte plus toute cette violence et le
reste me prouve que j'ai bien fait parce
que ça aurait dégénéré où le raisin
spectacle misérable comme celui que
vient de faire eric naulleau alors quand
même que je dise à siri dan dah parce
que peut-être que vous y avez trouvé
votre bon goût
le nombre de gens qui ont écouté ça mais
moi aussi figuré parce que sur ma
plateforme arm pour point fr jeu
gagner trois mille 500 parrainages dans
la soirée c'était ensuite tu vas voir
c'est pas fini ma chaîne youtube années
passées à 490 milliards gâteau à 110
pour moi ça a été super positif et puis
à des gens ça c'est plus drôle parce que
vous le savez que ce mois ci la canjet
de chez vous ouais bon il ya toutes
sortes de gens qui avaient à dire en a
bien sûr à là-bas parce que ceci parce
que cela et il ya des tas de gens qui
nous ont découvert alors le drôle ce
matin c'était de voir comment il
commentait un e
j'aime pas d'habitude mais là je dois
dire 2 1 alors je crois qu'il ya des
gens qui vous ont apprécié dans cette
affaire et qui ont vu quelque chose en
vous petit qui est la cause pour
laquelle moi je vous ai fait confiance
c'est une forme d'empathie que vous avez
avec les gens par exemple vous m'avez
posé des questions extrêmement
recommande ir picanto mois durant temps
un petit me blesse sur l'antisémitisme
et où j'ai pu répondre mais vous l'avez
fait avec une manière de parler tient à
aucun moment de santé l'agressivité
l'envi dong yi he de douala et moi
j'apprécie que je n'ai peur d'aucune
question d'aucun débat vous pensez bien
depuis le temps que j'en mets ce que je
ne supporte plus ces kantien 7e
je sens une volonté voiliers de nuire
d'être d'être violent que j'aie
regrettez vous voyez je vous parle
franchement j'ai eu un revers un peu
brutale avec le bayer j'ai ouï à un
moment donné vous savez on était trois
quarts alors elle n'arrêtait pas de
dates à venir et c'est bien son droit et
bon abandonnant jeudi l'article depuis
l'incident sous jacente est tendue je le
regrette parce que c'est pas le genre de
répartie qu'il faut faire alors mais
voilà je suis comme tout le monde un
être humain et arrive des fois d'aller
un peu plus loin que le trait mais je
trouve que lamentable que je ne voudrais
pas qu'on aurait sur la perception que
c'était une émission tendu où des
acteurs parlant c'était une émission
sincère france plein de gens aux mêmes
ont écouté ce qui s'est dit avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et moi aussi et je
regrette pas bon je ne regrette pas
d'avoir dit je ne veux pas me trouver
dans la situation de violence pour le
reste du choisi personnes et les gens
m'ont dit ce petit boulet j'ai répondu à
tous
jean-luc si vous voulez bien on va
rester là cyril parce que j'en ai je ne
ferai pas de débat jean-luc juste plus
que l'autre soir jean-luc à yaya
françois mitterrand qui vous regarde
derrière je le vois le voit derrière
vous voyez ils vous regardent et nous
surveille merci merci jean luc en tout
cas merci beaucoup merci alors même sort
tout cas merci merci jean luc hees et
val et la brillantissime avocate qui
partiraient d'affaires fait d'une fois
ce soir et ben merci jean luc eric bana
la séquence est assez édifiante la
france insoumise se répartit entre la
censure qui avait représenté par jean
luc mélenchon il l'a exercé à mon
endroit
j'en ai pas fait tout un pataquès j'ai
appelé personne ni la prime a dit oui
mais pas à pelé ni la production ni
d'autres honecker ni personne et par
raquel garrido qui représente ici le
mensonge puisque contre toute évidence
elle continue à répéter ben oui c'est
toi qui a fait les suit pas ce que t'as
pas supporté non j'ai eu un quart
d'heure ça m'a énervé parce qu'on n'aime
pas être évincé d'une émission personne
même lettre je me suis résigné et une
fois que cyril s'est exprimé j'ai fait
un tweet très neutre en disant comme
l'expliqué cyril je ne serai pas présent
ce soir à la demande de jean luc
mélenchon mais je vous donne rendez-vous
pour l'after où nous parlerons du sort
des sans abri pendant la vague de grand
froid
ça a été la fin du tout ici c'est un
tweet d'hystérique moi je veux bien
alors il faut redéfinir une série après
quand jean-luc mélenchon dit qu'il aime
pas l'agressivité
je me souviens et tout le monde personne
n'a oublié la séquence la république
c'est moi ou même image et j'ai écouté
l'émission mais disons que l'agressivité
c'est plus souvent lui qui la représente
peu moins d'un revirement